you know the YouGov said the reason that
Biden's ahead is because of women the
female vote okay that makes sense but
Trump is winning with independents so
iten's ahead because of women are voting
for him
because women don't like Trump in a men
women don't like Trump and all I can
think is all the different creepy videos
of him grabbing women and sniffing their
hair and children emotional instability
if you if you can see address me out of
Joe Biden doing these things and say
from anyway you're not you're there's
nothing there's nothing going on
upstairs yeah man
it's it's you know but there is around
it I don't know what's gonna happen you
know that 7 or 68 percent about 70
percent of millennial women are
Democrats I didn't know that now yeah
they're gonna vote for Biden okay that's
so weird isn't it yeah it is it's
creating a weird dating phenomenon I
don't know if we talked about this
before but like if there's there's very
few conservative women okay millennial
women Republicans and that means that
the dating pool for Democratic women is
extremely lopsided so what's actually
happened from this is we've seen stories
of millennial women becoming
conservative because they can't get a
boyfriend yeah I read an article
yesterday I just kind of random but it
was this left girl like a democratic
woman said her family was okay with all
these different things but then they
couldn't accept that that she was
marrying a Trump fan like a Trump you
know supporter oh right right couldn't
go around to it that's the woman who
wanted someone to walk her down the
aisle ergo yeah and so Trump jr. said he
would do it oh really yeah I don't catch
that part of the story he knew he
tweeted if you don't find someone better
I'll do it and everyone's like yeah but
that's the thing about like it's all so
sad
Oh totally that's so sad like really
you're that petty that you won't go to
your daughter's wedding they're
seriously there are some crazy posts
I've seen where like Trump supporters
gay Trump supporters post about how it
was harder to come out as a trump
supporter than it wasn't come out as gay
yeah because people are deranged it's
insane yeah it's really nuts there was a
recent post where someone said that
it was harder to come out as Trump
supporter than trans like when they went
to their family and said they were trans
their family was like yeah and happy and
like dancing you know maybe that was the
article I read actually the train sounds
familiar yeah but when they said they
want to vote for Trump the family like
yeah where's that invasion of the body
snatchers where the guy goes points and
reaches I don't think I've seen that
yeah yeah yeah the 70s I know that
aliens take over their body I don't like
the woman's running up and the guy sees
her and goes like points that are in
screams nice that's what it's like man
it's you know I couldn't imagine what it
would be like to actually be in New York
and hanging out with some of these
people that I just hang out with I told
you the story I talked about that before
the girl who asked me how many of my
male friends were okay with rape I told
you that right no I talked about this
yeah I remember you talking to me yeah
yeah we know but we talked about on the
show sorry but now I don't well I
thought we talked about this on the show
you know maybe we just talked about it I
worked with someone in media okay and we
were hanging out one day and then all of
a sudden she was like so be honest with
me to him like how many this was this
was in where we lived on Nostrand
seriously I was hanging out with her in
the park on the playground yeah those
benches okay and she was asking about
you she said is it she said not you
specifically but like I'm your friend so
and it was at this time when I'm hanging
out in the apartment everything okay
telling Magic the Gathering yeah and she
said be honest like how many of your
dick male friends are like cool with
rape yeah and I was like why no like
seriously
yeah before I'll be honest like how many
of your male friends are like cool with
rape and I was like none of them and she
goes honestly and I was like all right
are you joking
like are you being serious right now
that's ridiculous it was like yes like
how many of your guy friends you know
they'll laugh about it and they'll like
you know brag about how they've done it
and I'm like what they believe that
that's what she said to me and this was
like a feminist UW theme and she's I
don't know anybody either for the record
I was like ridiculous like dude what if
I said if we were hanging out my
goodness and one dude started bragging
about how he liked to rape somebody yeah
probably
yeah absolutely well we look at him at
first and back you're joking right and
if they were serious he'd be like I'm
gonna leave ya like I don't want to be
here not the person we thought you were
basically it's not just that like we
would never hang out with someone like
that
like you meet a person like that and you
don't hang out with them so but she but
she asked me this I just saw someone
someone in the chat said something that
I kind of maybe thought it was like they
said she probably has a fetish and that
does exist doesn't it I don't what you
like she's trying to find a guy who's no
no I'm not necessarily what she's
thinking but isn't that doesn't that
exist like there are women of course
Bernie Sanders that's what he said right
what about it worse they're not normal
but no no no it is because it's not it's
not about like but the fetish is no no
guys talking like oh right Rowan out
about rape no but I know normal but
think about why I've never met any guy
that has ever like hey you wanted to you
wanna talk about rape right what kind of
indoctrination happened to her where she
believed that men do that like I'm sure
there are some creepy mm efforts yeah
who are laughing okay but like the
average dude III starts in the news you
know when that happens so I guess I
don't know the social justice side is
like oh yeah more ammunition for our
guns against its toxic masculinity or
whatever else they they and at a
constant one-upping each other yeah I
don't believe anything and then people
get roped into this and I you know I was
talking to I was talking her about it
and I'm like you realize that like the
actual male male power fantasy is like
saving a woman like good point you know
like fairytales are about the man in
shining armor rescuing the damsel in
distress being not kidnapping her and
bragging to his friends about like
destroying her yeah that's always the
bad guy in the movies right I was
talking about this when you were gone we
did a segment about like making life a
video game basically you know like we go
into video games like I'm a gamer
obviously so it's like you know
I get to rescue the hero or the woman
you know it's like well I saved I save
the planet you know you know so everyone
wants to be heroes you know let me just
let me finish this is like so you know
it my lost go ahead spelunky we're
talking I'm gonna say you can choose to
rescue a man woman or dog oh that's true
yeah yeah yeah I didn't know that
so you're mentioning lettings you're
saying you go to the settings and change
it so that you're not rescuing them and
you can rescue a man oh that's nice or a
dog right so people yet people want to
rescue we don't want to be heroes we
don't want to not there like respirate
people gosh right yeah what so so it's
cringy yes I think it's a it's scary it
is scary it was freaky when I heard this
I was like you can't really believe this
do you she did totally did and I
remember like when I worked for it was
when I was working for fusion total like
progressive far laugh everything yeah
the propaganda was everywhere you know
that like one woman had a dollar in her
cubicle you get a dollar pin to the the
wall and she drew a line at the 23
percent mark and scribbled on it and
then she put like a post-it note
pointing to it saying something about
like like what she had to overcome or
something the wage gap Oh uh-huh it's
fake it's it's like it's it's completely
fabricated you know man when you see
Barack Obama he got up and said
something like for every dollar a man
earns a woman earned 77 cents that is
wrong that's like his famous thing yeah
I remember when you when you see that
and you know it's not true you know
Obama knows it's not true
ya know he's lying to you when Donald
Trump gets up there and set talks like
you know like says crazy stuff talks
off-the-cuff no he's just talking out
the company's wrong a lot yeah there's a
big difference
Trump lies though for sure they all do
they're all politicians I don't care
yeah but like to believe that your side
is the hero you know especially
particularly the Democrats III view them
right now as completely just like your
episode of Rick and Morty where they go
into the cleansing thing yeah and then
the the slime versions of them is the
Democratic Party right now yeah like I
don't even what they're doing I don't
know either yeah the other the other the
other joke I like to make is uh
the moderate Democrats who won the Trump
districts in 2018
it's like they came out and said if you
vote for us we're not gonna do this
partisanship stuff we're gonna fight for
real issues the economy you know jobs
health care kitchen table issues that
you care about yeah and then as soon as
they got elected they just went full-on
for impeachment and it's like the the
the joke is the Lord of the Rings meme
oh yeah sudden yes the gasoline to the
fire and the moderate Democrats are
holding orange man bad look at it they
smile no man do it alone that's what it
was so I can't him out we'll see what
happens come November these people get
reelected I have no idea thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you